ich möchte einmal wieder über corona
sprechen und zwar hat jens spanier etwas
ganz fantastisches verkündet er will die
epidemische lage von nationaler
tragweite
auslaufen lassen er selbst hat das zwar
gar nicht zu entscheiden das macht der
bundestag auch ganz ohne jens spahn aber
pr technisch ist das natürlich ganz toll
für den gesundheitsminister der
anderthalb jahre lang wirklich im
absoluten knallharte modus regiert hat
jetzt auch mal was positives zu
verkünden aber man muss sich doch die
frage stellen warum haben wir eine
epidemische lager warum haben wir
überhaupt ein crooner ausnahmezustand
wir haben gerade einen total entspannten
sommer hinter uns man kann sich die
todeszahlen die inzidenz zahlen die
krankenhauseinweisungen anschauen da war
wirklich nicht so viel los zumindest
nicht so viel dass es auch nur
ansatzweise ein crooner ausnahmezustand
rechtfertigte und daraus lernt man dass
die regierung sich diese rechtsgrundlage
geschaffen hat obwohl sie sie überhaupt
nicht braucht eigentlich sollte man auf
krisen ja dann reagieren wenn sie
wirklich da sind und sich nicht mal
präventiv irgendwelche sonderrechte
herausnehmen und ja einfach mal schauen
was dann kommt auch wenn erst mal
überhaupt nichts kommt und das ist für
mich die große lehre aus der krone
pandemie der staat hat sich kroner macht
gesichert und will sie auch nicht
abgeben und das macht mir leider
wirklich sorge
philipp das ist sicherlich ein punkt der
der heute sehr sehr wichtig war und was
steht denn in diesem infektions gesetz
schutzgesetz drin das ist das eine
eine eine epidemische lage vorträgt von
nationaler tragweite vorliegt wenn eine
ernsthafte gefahr für die öffentliche
gesundheit besteht und du sagst das war
nicht der fall ich finde das war schon
der fall wenn wir sehen welche folgen
corona hatte auch in den
intensivstationen in ihrem letzten
nächte hatte es da hatte ich ja es waren
natürlich viele viele menschen auf den
intensivstationen
das haben wir die statistik haben wir
gesehen dass wenn viele menschen
gestorben wir werden bald eine runde
zahl von verstorbenen auch in
deutschland also insofern amt viele
menschen sind verstorben ältere war
nicht geimpft 70 80 jährige sind
gestorben an krone ich bin selbst
wirklich viel
angehörige und das kann man auch nicht
regieren da sollten wir auch nicht tun
egal
insofern muss roman allgemeinmedizin
würde mich auch 70 80 jährige zählt für
mich zur allgemeinheit und sänger haben
doch das ist schon die frage und sind
gestorben jens spahn hat darauf
hingewiesen dass er glaubt daher die
anpassung an schätzung nicht dass man
das jetzt beenden kann und diese
dreimonatsfrist auslaufen lassen kann du
hast recht philipp es sind nicht ist
nicht der der minister der dafür
zuständig ist sondern dass der bundestag
der sowas alle drei monate entscheiden
muss und es sind die gesundheitsminister
der länder die diese entscheidung dann
auch umsetzen müssten und eigentlich
auch gemeinschaftlich umsetzen müssen
aber ein minister und dass wir nicht gut
an jens spahn muss natürlich ein zeichen
setzen und vorangehen insofern wenn die
sein wichtiges signal von ihm zu sagen
also ich finde die lage hat sich
verändert tut etwas damit jemand der
solches gewicht hat der bringt schon
etwas voran in dieser frage heraus doch
wie sehen sie das denn hatte deutschland
im sommer ein crooner ausnahmezustand
der das gerechtfertigt hat dass wir so
lange der epidemischen lage waren nein
das oberziel war ja immer keine
überlastung unseres gesundheitssystems
und jeder der an corona co wird 19
erkrankt soll die notwendige
medizinische behandlung bekommen
einschließlich intensivmedizinischer
behandlung einschließlich künstliche
beamten da war nie eine überlastung
unseres gesundheitssystems aber wir
hatten eine fragile lage und weil man
nicht abschätzen konnte wie werden sich
im herbst die zahlen entwickeln nicht
nur infektionen sondern auch schwerer
verläufe hat man für drei monate diese
epidemische lage von nationaler
tragweite beschlossen und würde ich
jeden satz unterschreiben den herrn
anderer gesagt hat ich habe nur eine
andere sorgen nämlich dass wir uns
langsam daran gewöhnen dass der
begründungspflicht ist der seine
freiheitsrechte der namen spruch nehmen
möchte der regelfall muss genau
umgekehrt sein der staat muss begründen
warum er in die freiheitsrechte ein
grund der aktuell noch richtig ist dass
wir beispielsweise maske tragen müssen
dass ich war zum beispiel woche in
holland und da ist es jetzt beispiel
schon weg österreich auch was ich am
schlimmsten finde herr boss doch muss
ich sagen ich bin am schlimmsten
persönlich es wurde nie unterbrochen
der zustand wurde unterbrochen zum
beispiel in österreich wo die masken
zurückgenommen aber ich bin es wirklich
verteilt deutschland hat es einfach nie
unterbrochen aber es waren ja nicht
immer die selben zahlen und dieselben
kurven also wie kann es denn sein dass
wir nie auch meine lockerung macht haus
gar nicht genau sagen weil der
überwiegende teil der bevölkerung nicht
nur dafür war sondern sich auch
strengere regeln hat vorstellen können
und das ist richtig wir haben gott und
hosenträger genommen safety first es
gibt andere dinge die haben mich mehr
aufgeregt im flugzeug herrscht ein
strenges regiment und
anschließend stehst du im flughafenbus
nase an nase eine viertelstunde da sagt
kein mensch was ja das ist es gibt viele
kuriositäten
aber jetzt wird es zeit weil wir auch
sehen dass die schweren verläufe weniger
werden uns auf den schutz derjenigen zu
konzentrieren die in besonderer weise
gefährdet sind nach
impfungen von eltern jedoch aber immer
schon die pflicht des staates gewesen
sich auf die zu konzentrieren das haben
ja das haben wir also das haben wir
nicht in der intensität getan vor einem
jahr wie wir es heute tun muss schreiben
wurde auch versagt
ja man wollte ein mann wollte den locker
und für alle anstatt die zu schützen die
es wirklich nötig hatten jene die das
gefordert haben übrigens die gesagt
haben wie hendrik streik auch wie
christian lindner zum beispiel die
gesagt wir müssen jetzt die altenheime
schützen da sterben über 50 prozent der
menschen also 50 prozent aller krone
totenkopf aus altenheim da hat die
bundeskanzlerin gesagt nein nein man
kann nicht millionen von menschen
wegsperren aber da ging es gar nicht
darum es ging darum vor heim zu testen
yamaha wo viele isolieren an die risiken
und nebenwirkungen hat man dabei nicht
gehabt selbst weil mama erlebt in der
zeit zwei mann im krankenhaus kein
besuch gar nichts ja das war schlimm
aber wir können jetzt alle damit meine
ich gar nicht sie aber der frau daher
reden wir haben so etwas auch noch nie
erlebt also eine solche pandemie eine
weltweite pandemie mit einer solchen
aussage von einem erreger den keiner
kannte wo ist doch unterschiedlichste
vorstellung gab aber anfangen sollten
wir doch noch nicht mal maske tragen so
hießen willkommene ausrede war jetzt
kann auch einmal sagen jetzt na ja wir
wussten nicht nein dauert seine zeit bis
man erst mal gefunden gewusst haben wo
kommt dieser erreger her oder sprechen
nicht über die fehler der ersten wochen
wir sprechen ja darüber was im letzten
jahr passiert ist also als man schon
sechs monate keine erfahrung hatten
erstens zweitens haben andere länder ist
ja anders gemacht auch mit wissen und
mit überzeugung und wenn man sich mal
die inzidenz zahlen aber auch den die
todeszahlen anschaut deutschland und
schweden die letzten zwölf monate das
eine land sechs monate im lockdown das
andere land komplett ohne dann verlaufen
diese kurven komplett parallel der lese
ich auch unterschiedlichen
stellungnahmen darüber tatsächlich ich
habe im sommer habe ich ganz
unterschiedliche dinge darüber gewesen
dass schweden das modell nämlich
überhaupt nicht funktioniert und das
modell voll gegen die wand gefahren ist
also das stimme eines von beiden kann ja
nur stimmen aber ja aber aber in dem
moment wo für alle ein impfstoff erbost
war sie haben gesagt für alle ein
impfstoff zur verfügung stand da hätte
doch der staat die verantwortung zurück
geben müsst jetzt kannst du dich impfen
nun sie zu was hat der staat ja auch
lange kündigte brown im märz angekündigt
und das versprechen einfach die moral
ist das nicht passiert weil in dem
moment wo sie sich schützen können sind
sie für sich selbst verantwortlich sie
sagen ja auch ich rauche oder ich auch
nicht wir haben an die sie für andere
verantwortlich ist hier auch nur sicher
sondern auch schon sich ja ja das ist ja
richtig aber man kann sich dann und in
dem moment muss man es noch als
übergriff des staates empfinden wenn er
den locker und beibehält oder die ganzen
ausläufer mit ihnen bis jetzt zu tun
haben die masken wenn denn dafür keine
grundlage besteht wir dürfen ja nicht
vergessen es gaby wehrens in la coruna
wasser und über die tote und über die
erkranken wir reden nicht über die
psychologischen folgen das heißt wir
halten immer es ist immer was passiert
der krone auch während der maßnahmen wir
haben einen preis gezahlt und zwar haben
wir den auch auf dem rücken der kinder
gezahlt als weil es nicht wir machen
einen locker angeht super toll wenn
keine psychologischen folgen runde ist
superklasse für alle menschen beschützen
sollen wir haben auch geschadet und da
hab ich mir als bürgerin von der
kanzlerin auch manchmal eine abwägung
mehr gewünscht ich finde wir deutschen
sind freiheits voll geworden und haben
uns also ich finde wir können uns bei
den kindern und bei den heranwachsenden
später mal wirklich entschuldigen tja
und das ist genau der punkt man wusste
am anfang vielleicht nicht wie schulen
wie kinder betroffen sind man wusste
dass dann aber im sommer 2020 und andere
länder haben wir reagiert die schweiz
beispielsweise hat nach dem ersten lok
dann gesagt alles klar wir machen die
schulen navigation hat sie auch offen
gelassen und deshalb bestens
funktioniert ganz viele länder ähnlich
und kein land hat so lange die schulen
dicht gelassen bedeutet aber sichtbar
und dafür die hat die kanzlerin sich
eingesetzt sie hat die mpk ist
unterbrochen um druck aufzubauen auf die
ministerpräsident mit dem einzigen zweck
die schulen zu zu machen sie hat nichts
dafür getan um sie zu öffnen aber wo ist
verraten ja unterschiedliche regelungen
in den bundesländern und wir hatten
tatsächlich das ist so dass keine
ausrede kein historisches vorbild es
wurde immer rekurriert auf die spanische
grippe von vor 100 jahren und wir
erleben dass wir ganz unterschiedliche
verläufe und infektionsketten haben
selbst im bundesgebiet ich empfehle man
los und south dakota von den
sozioökonomischen daten vergleichbar
zwei nachbarländer in den in den usa
zwar ganz unterschiedliche wege aber die
verläufe waren gar nicht so
unterschiedlich das heißt man hat auch
während der pandemie viel gelernt aber
im moment sind wir dabei die diese
kritik teile ich im moment sind wir
dabei die vorsicht zu sehr zu betonen
vor der freiheit obwohl wir mittlerweile
impfquoten von 65 70 ich glaube über 80
prozent oder ja nur ich würde mal sagen
also das ist ja alles schön wenn wir
alle überzeugt sind uns kann gar nichts
mehr passieren ich lese aber andere
dinge ich gucke mir die statistik an ich
sehe bayern die ganzen grenzgebiete das
sind wir ins ident sind zum teil von 100
200 300 und
das ist wieder so wie den härtesten
zeiten ich lese immer mehr von
angeblichen impft durchbrüchen muss mir
nur jemand erklären gibt es die oder
gibt es die nicht doppelt geimpft
trotzdem corona intensivstation was
passiert mit denen ich lese immer mehr
von jungen menschen die jetzt auch in
den krankenhäusern nehmen gibt es die
gibt es die nicht wir tun jetzt alle so
als wäre corona vorbei und ich lese auch
dass corinna uns nie verlassen
da sie einfach jetzt mal nach hause
diskutieren wir haben sind kleine mini
unterbrechen zb man erfährt diskutieren
zu hause auf der eigentlich im netzwerk
oder nicht und wir sind gleich wieder
zurück
[Musik]